from those humble beginnings you are now
a billionaire
how has money changed your life or maybe
the landscape of experience in your life
does it buy happiness it doesn't buy
happiness but it buys you a level of
comfort for you to really amplify What
happiness is
I kind of think about it in the
following way let's just say that
there's a a hundred things on the table
and the table says find happiness here
and there are different prices
the way that the world works
is that many of these experiences are
cordoned off a little bit behind the
Velvet Rope
where
you think that there's more happiness as
the prices of things escalate right if
you live in an apartment you admire the
person with the house
if you live in a house you admire the
person with the bigger house
that person admires the person with you
know
um an island right
um
some person drives their car admires a
person who flies who admires a person
who flies business class who admires a
person who flies first
you know to private there's all of these
escalations on this table
and most people get to the first five or
six
and so they just naturally assume that
items you know seven through a hundred
is really where happiness is found
and the just to you know tell you the
the Finish Line I've tried a hundred and
back and I've tried to 400 to it uh and
happiness isn't there
um
but it does give you a level of comfort
I read a study
and I don't know if it's true or not but
it said that
um the absolute sort of like maximal
link between money and happiness
is around 50 million dollars
and there was a it was just like a
social studies kind of thing that I
think one of the Ivy Leagues put out and
underneath it the way that they
explained it was because you could have
a home you could have all kinds of the
Creature Comforts you could take care of
your family
um and then you were left to ponder
what it is that you really want
I think the challenge for most people is
to realize that
this escalating arms race of you know
more things will solve your problems is
not true
um
more and better is not the solution it's
it's this idea that
you
are on a very precise Journey that's
unique to yourself you are playing a
game
of which only you are the player
everybody else is an interloper
and you have a responsibility to design
the gameplay
and I think a lot of people don't
realize that because if they did I think
they would make a lot of different
decisions about how they live their life
and I still do the same thing I mean
revert
to basically running around asking other
people what will make you like me more
you know what will make me more popular
in your eyes and I try to do it and it
never works
um it is just a complete dead end is
there negative aspects to money like for
example
it becoming harder to find people you
can trust
I think the most negative aspect is that
it amplifies
a 360 degree view of your personality
because there are a lot of people and
Society tells you that more money is
actually better you are a better person
somehow
and you're factually more worthwhile
than some other people that have less
money that's also a lie but when you're
given that kind of attention it's very
easy for you to become a caricature of
yourself
um that's probably the single worst
thing that happens to you but I say it
in the opposite way I think all I've
ever seen in Silicon Valley as an
example
um is that when somebody gets a hold of
a lot of money it tends to cause them to
become exactly who they were meant to be
they're either a kind person they're
either a curious person they're either a
jerk you know they're either cheap and
they can use all kinds of masks but now
that there's no expectations and Society
gives you a get out of jail free card
you start to behave the way that's most
comfortable to you so you see somebody's
innate personality
and that's a really interesting thing to
observe because then you can very
quickly bucket sort where do you want to
spend time and who is really you know
additive to your gameplay
and who is really a negative detractor
to your gameplay you're an investor but
you're also a kind of philosopher
um you analyze the world in all these
different uh perspectives on all in
podcasts on Twitter everywhere uh
do you worry that money makes puts you
out of touch
from
being able to truly empathize with the
experience of the general population
which in part first of all on a human
level that could be limiting but also as
an analyst of human civilization that
could be limiting
I think it definitely can for a lot of
people because it's just a it's an
abstraction for you to stop caring right
um I also think the other thing is that
you can very quickly especially in
today's world become the scapegoat just
to use the gerardian like Renee Gerard
if you look if you think about like
memetic theory in a nutshell
you know we're all competing
for these very scarce resources that we
are told is worthwhile and if you view
the world through that gerardian lens
what are we really doing we're all
fighting for scarce resources whether
that's Twitter followers money Acclaim
notoriety and we all compete with each
other and in that competition
you know Gerard writes like the only way
you escape that Loop is by scapegoating
something or somebody
and I think we are in that Loop right
now where just the fact of being
successful is a thing that one should
scapegoat to end all of this you know
tension that we have in the world
I I think that it's a little misguided
because I don't think it solves the
fundamental problem
um and we can talk about the solution to
some of these problems are but
um that's I think the loop that we're
all living and so if you become a
character caricature and you feed
yourself into it
I mean you're not doing anything to to
Really Advance things